in today's world it's not hard to find
yourself being recorded with an
explosion I feel like it's happening
right now with an explosion in security
cameras and recording devices in
virtually every pocket private moments
may not be so private after all what
transpires on those recordings can tell
us a lot in this morning's reporters
notebook we examine the good the bad and
the ugly of secretly recorded behavior
from parking lots to the West Wing one
test of a person's character is if they
do the right thing when they don't think
anybody's looking this week a grand jury
report showed that the Catholic Church
of Pennsylvania failed that test at the
White House staffers were facing that
test daily as recordings were released
by former top trump official Omarosa
Manigault newman general kelly came to
me and said that you guys wanted me to
leave weeks ago the president's former
lawyer michael cohen released a
recording showing candidate Donald Trump
talking about hush money payments to an
alleged mistress that President Trump
had said he knew nothing about when it
comes time for the financing which will
be Newman says she kept pressing record
to defend against her lying colleagues
which meant she was taking a tax payer
salary to promote the virtues of people
she was privately recording because they
had no virtue although over the last
many months backstabbing private
comments by Anthony scaramouche II and
Steve Bannon
suggest that Newman wasn't the only one
playing a double game
worldly people say all of this private
deceit is just what happens in politics
but rather than recline into that
cynicism consider for a moment the case
of Sue Johnson Johnson was the woman who
braved the rain and the wind to return a
shopping cart to Walmart
turns out returning a shopping cart can
tell us something about your character
according to Scientific American those
of us who returned shopping carts do so
because we're worried about the people
who would have to collect them if we
didn't this empathy is the basic
building block of public service you're
not in it just for your cell
for for your tribe imagine if we could
measure for this quaint notion when
picking public servants and those who
work for them can they pass the Sue
Johnson test instead of achieving
excellence in front of reality show
cameras will they do the right thing
when they don't think the cameras are
rolling that is the question that is
such a good question do you do the right
thing when nobody is watching you pass
the shopping cart test yeah it should be
a litmus test for all politician you
know how would we how do we construct
that though it would have to be you have
to be difficult but John you had a lot
of material to work with this way yeah a
lot of material yeah I don't think it's
gonna stop me yeah no looking forward to
next week maybe there'll be more tapes
that come out you can dice yeah it's
like that's undoubtedly true John thank
you yeah it's great